I’m really interested in this question and
I’m glad you asked about it.
This is a question of how do Americans value
life?
Is every life equally valuable to an American?
I would argue it’s not, and there’s some
evidence of that.
We know precisely how many Americans have
been killed in uniform since 9/11.
We know the number – there’s a website
that will tell you tomorrow what the number
is to the last to man.
But tens of thousands, maybe even hundreds
of thousands of Iraqis, Afghans, Yemenis,
Somalis have died, not always at our hands,
often in internecine warfare, but we can hardly
count.
And the American people hardly care exactly
how many civilians died in the last drone
strike or exactly how many Iraqis died in
the course of the civil war.
It seems that the American people are completely
disjointed from this war.
If they take a moment to think on it, it’s
just enough to wave a flag, stick a bumper
sticker on their car with a yellow ribbon,
maybe stand for the pledge and clap for the
latest service member on the field in the
NFL.
Most Americans aren’t paying any attention
to the military.
And I’ll say I think one reason why this
is, one part is race.
There’s no denying it.
This is very uncomfortable for people to deal
with, but we fight brown people.
Usually we fight Arabs, we fight Pashto in
Afghanistan and other ethnic groups.
These people don’t necessarily look like
the traditional American, and so their lives
have less value.
How do we know this?
When there was a terrorist attack in Belgium
and, say, 20 people are killed, well those
are Europeans; they kind of look like Americans.
It’s days of coverage.
Every single individual face is on the screen
even if they’re not American citizens.
Every Caucasian face is accounted for when
there’s a terrorist attack, and it’s the
narrative or for days, which is hard to do
in this news cycle.
But what about the next day, when 140 people
are killed in Turkey in a terrorist attack,
also perpetrated by ISIS, also perpetrated
on innocent people?
We will never see the faces of those Turks.
We might not even get the exact number.
They’ll say, “Approximately 140 people
were killed in an attack,” and it’s going
to be on the Chyron.
And so I think we have to ask ourselves a
question, which is: if America is truly to
be engaged around the world, as we are, with
hundreds of military bases abroad—we’re
the only people who do this by the way—if
we are to be so engaged in the world then
I can’t help but wonder if we ought to be
more sensitive to the value of life in the
regions of which we are either occupiers,
invaders, or humanitarians, depending on your
point of view.
I’m not even going to necessarily weigh
in on that, I think it’s a little bit of
both or a little of all.
But I think you bring up a great question,
which is: American lives clearly matter, but
if we truly believe that all lives matter,
we sure don’t act like it in the media space.
And that disturbs someone like me who grew
to love Iraqis and Afghanis, especially Iraqis,
who were the first people that I really dealt
with in uniform.
And I fell in love with these people.
Because you know what most of them want to
do?
They want to wake up; they want to go to work;
they want to take care of a family.
And they’re innocent.
They’re as innocent and as valuable as we
are as Americans, and we’re in their countries.
We are guests, often uninvited guests, but
we are guests.
And I think it’s really important to value
life there.
I don’t think we do enough of it at home—or
abroad.